[Música]
hola soy una paria cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
frenos 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos allí
en una decisión histórica el jurado
declaró culpable del homicidio de la
prestado unidense georges lloyd al ex
policía derecho vi un hecho que desató
las mayores manifestaciones en rechazo
al racismo estructural en la unión
americana y que se replicó en el mundo
hoy crecen los llamados por la
aprobación de una reforma a la policía
en el congreso
y más de setenta candidatos a las
elecciones más grandes de la historia de
mexico que se celebrarán el 6 de junio
han sido denunciados por algún tipo de
violencia contra las mujeres el caso más
emblemático es el del aspirante a la
gobernación del estado de guerrero pero
muchos más son señalados organizaciones
feministas piden a los directores
investigar quiénes son sus
representantes y en nicaragua ejercer la
libertad de expresión en redes sociales
puede llevarte a la cárcel apenas en
abril se han registrado 350 agresiones
policiales a opositores según denuncian
dos observatorios hablamos con una
activista que ha sido detenido tres
veces por su contenido en tics
y empezamos en eeuu con la imagen de la
semana el expolicía dark show bussiness
esposado después de que fue declarado
culpable por el asesinato del
afroamericano georges light en mayo de
2000 20 tras deliberar durante 10 horas
por dos días el jurado lo encontró
culpable por lo que el hombre blanco se
enfrenta a una condena de hasta 40 años
de prisión chauvín se arrodilló durante
nueve minutos en el cuello de floyd
mientras él decía no puedo respirar una
frase que se convirtió en insignia del
movimiento black life smarter que se
tomó de eeuu en protestas desde la costa
este hasta la oeste y que motivó una
revisión profunda del racismo
estructural en la nación e incluso en el
mundo pues las protestas se replicaron
en rechazo a casos locales y al
colonialismo y se manifestaron con el
derribo de estatuas en varias ciudades
de américa europa y áfrica
miles de personas salieron a las calles
a celebrar la decisión del jurado que es
histórica pues en la unión americana es
muy raro que el sistema penal
responsabiliza a los policías de
asesinatos ocurridos durante el
ejercicio de sus funciones en menos del
2% de los casos que terminan con
víctimas mortales los policías
implicados son juzgados por asesinato a
pesar de que aproximadamente 1000
personas mueren al año en incidentes
policiales
solamente 139 policías han sido
arrestados desde 2005 y de ellos
solamente 44 fueron condenados esto
debido a una combinación de poderosos
sindicatos policiales estándares legales
que le dan el beneficio de la duda y una
tradición de protección
entre quienes celebraron está el
presidente joe biden que lo calificó
como un momento de cambio significativo
para eeuu y volvió a hacer un llamado al
senado a actuar con rapidez con miras a
una reforma policial el proyecto de ley
y justicia por georges light ya fue
aprobado en la cámara de representantes
pero les explicamos que tan posible es
que reciba el visto bueno del senado
wicked y desmond aprovechar el momento
ese fue el mensaje del presidente you by
then tras conocerse el veredicto en
contra de derechos o bing
el mandatario estadounidense exhortó una
vez más al senado a aprobar una reforma
a la policía
nadie debe estar sobre la ley
el veredicto envía ese mensaje pero no
es suficiente
no podemos detenernos aquí para entregar
un cambio verdadero debemos y podemos
hacer más para evitar que este tipo de
tragedias se repitan para asegurarnos de
que los negros y mestizos y de que nadie
le tenga miedo a sus interacciones con
la policía
pero a pesar de que incluso algunos
republicanos están de acuerdo con el
veredicto contra de chopin hay varios
puntos de discordia para aprobar la
legislación propuesta por los demócratas
lo que dificulta que avance en el /
senado estadounidense
la manzana de la discordia es la
inmunidad calificada
una medida que protege a los oficiales y
funcionarios públicos de ser procesados
en juicios civiles los republicanos se
oponen pero el líder negociador
republicano tim scott dio un paso hacia
la reconciliación al proponer que la
responsabilidad se traspase a los
departamentos de policía cuando cambia
la ley crear responsabilidad legal si
tienes una nueva categoría de
responsabilidad el comportamiento de la
gente cambia y eso es lo que es más
importante las agencias de las fuerzas
de la ley deben entrenar a los oficiales
a que se escala en la situación en wyss
el proyecto de ley que ya fue aprobado
en la cámara de representantes- necesita
al menos 10 votos republicanos en el
senado y propone prohibir maniobras de
ahogamiento entre otros mientras se
decide su futuro el departamento de
justicia inició una investigación sobre
las prácticas policiales en mineápolis
donde floyd fue asesinado
el llamado por la aprobación de la
reforma policial llegó hasta el funeral
de down write otro afro asesinado por la
policía también en mineápolis el 11 de
abril la oficial sin parar asegura que
tenía la intención de usar su arma de
electrochoque pero supuestamente por
error usó su arma de fuego y disparó
también será enjuiciada y es que
lamentablemente estos casos siguen
siendo comunes en eeuu
tan sólo esta semana la brutalidad
policial contra los afroamericanos ha
cobrado dos nuevas víctimas
andrew brown de 42 años y magia bryant
de 16 que fallecieron en carolina del
norte y ohio respectivamente
vamos a méxico que está en plena campaña
para las elecciones más grandes de su
historia más de 94 millones de personas
están convocadas a las urnas el próximo
6 de junio para elegir a 500 diputados
federales y casi 20.000 cargos estatales
entre ellos 15 de los 32 gobernadores
del país uno de ellos es david monreal
quien aspira a gobernar zacatecas en el
centro del país de la mano de morena el
partido del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador pero esta semana un vídeo
en el que se le ve tocando
inapropiadamente a otra candidata lo
puso en el centro de la controversia
veamos
estas imágenes tienen contra las cuerdas
a david monreal el aspirante a la
gobernación de zacatecas por el partido
oficialista morena en ella se ve como le
pasa la mano por la espalda a una mujer
y la toca inapropiadamente el vídeo fue
registrado durante el acto de campaña y
la mujer es su colega la candidata a la
presidencia municipal de juchipila rocío
moreno tras conocerse el vídeo el
candidato dijo que se trataba de una
manipulación lograda gracias a la
tecnología la candidata también salió en
su defensa no voy a permitir que me
utilice no voy a permitir que nuevamente
dañen al movimiento el licenciado david
monreal es una persona respetuosa y
nunca me ha faltado basta de calumnias
basta de utilizar los vídeos para dañar
nuestras imágenes este es sólo uno de
los candidatos a los tantos cargos de
elección popular que están en juego el 6
de junio salpicados por algún tipo de
denuncia o agresión contra la mujer el
colectivo feminista las brujas del mar
expuso una lista de 40 aspirantes de 10
partidos señalados de agresión acoso
sexual violación e incluso pornografía
infantil cuando
aplicas para un trabajo ya es común que
te google sabe solo aunque busquen en
redes acerca de ti en que ondas andas
eso se me hace extraño que para que
justamente para tener cargos de elección
popular para representar municipios
ciudades estados o hasta el país no se
está haciendo este tipo de filtros en
los partidos políticos y eso nos queda
claro ha sido una gran cantidad la y
nosotras que somos una simple ciudadanas
o somos activistas o como ustedes verlo
este hemos podido recabar bastante
información quizás el caso más polémico
es el de félix salgado macedonio sobre
quien pesan dos acusaciones de violación
pese a las denuncias el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador mantuvo su
apoyo y tuvo que ser el instituto
nacional y electoral el que suspendiera
su candidatura pero por irregularidades
en sus informes de gastos de campaña lo
que desató una guerra judicial entre el
mandatario y el ente electoral que aún
está por resolverse es un mensaje
bastante claro ella para
ya no nos queda ninguna duda de que en
méxico lo último que le importa a la
clase política de este país entre otros
sectores es la vida y la integridad y la
dignidad de las mujeres en méjico y
realmente tu pidan por un lado nosotros
dijimos bueno lo están bajando pero por
otro es como muy agridulce saber que fue
por no por gastos de 19 mil pesos en
campaña o sea más o menos fueron como 19
mil pesos y no por las denuncias de
acoso sexual y violación que hay en sus
contra esas no fueron el tema y es que
las brujas denuncian que el instituto
nacional electoral aceptó la candidatura
de 10 personas que han cometido actos de
violencia política contra las mujeres
vamos a haití que vive una profunda
crisis política económica y social el
primer ministro y canciller renunciaron
tras el secuestro de un grupo de
religiosos esta semana tres sacerdotes
fueron liberados pero algunas personas
permanecen aún retenidas
y seguimos en nicaragua en enero la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos otorgó medidas cautelares de
protección para un tick tock er de 20
años se llama kevin monzón y ha sido
arrestado tres veces por usar sus redes
sociales para criticar al gobierno de
daniel ortega ahora afirma que no tiene
miedo a las amenazas que no paran
nuestro corresponsal en managua jorge
hurtado nos trae su historia
kevin monzón se define como un activista
digital es reconocido por sus sátiras
contra el gobierno de daniel ortega en
la red social tic tac
los tres arrestos pues ha sido terrible
para mí porque te puedo decir que me han
golpeado y también de igual manera me ha
amenazado directamente que me van a
matar que van a andar el chipote
nuevamente que me calle que no siga hoy
en día todo todo esa cosa me dice en
ello
el jovencito que afirma que no teme a
las constantes amenazas y asedio de
parte de afines al gobierno con una
restricción general a protestar en las
calles las redes sociales se han
convertido en una ventana para mostrar
su descontento
exactamente falla donde ellos me
detuvieron y me pidieron con el nombre
completo bueno está bien perfecto de
ello pero no me van a callar donde yo
esté estoy detenido atrás de una celda
aguantando miles de cosas pero yo voy a
seguir siempre resistencia defensores de
derechos humanos temen nuevos arrestos
con la aprobación el año pasado de una
ley de ciberdelitos que según el
gobierno pretende proteger a los
usuarios de redes sociales existen
demasiados es delito cibernético que
efectivamente no tienen los suficientes
argumentos legales en el código penal
para poder sancionarlos sin embargo lo
que estamos observando desde que esto es
una pauta o un arma que puede utilizar
el gobierno para seguir restringiendo
censurando lo que son las personas que
no están de acuerdo por razones
políticas si te puedo decir pues esta
ley quiere venir a callar el periodismo
quiere venir a callar a la gente que
está informando quiere venir a callar al
pueblo pues que está express está en las
redes sociales y por eso esa ley el
próximo mes de noviembre nicaragua
tendrá elecciones generales en un
ambiente muy polarizado por ahora este
tipo que juega a su libertad al subir un
nuevo vídeo
raúl castro renunció como primer
secretario del partido comunista en su
lugar fue nombrado el actual presidente
miguel díaz canel aunque es la primera
vez que el único partido legal de
cubanos era dirigido por un castro no
necesariamente empieza una nueva era
pues recordemos que díaz canel fue
designado por el propio gobierno cubano
y los integrantes de la familia castro
continúan en varios puestos de poder en
la isla
[Aplausos]
y me despido con un colombiano que hizo
historia
lo mejor
el chef juan manuel barrientos y su
restaurante el cielo en washington dice
fueron incluidos dentro de la guía
michelín 2021 convirtiéndose en el
primer representante de su país en
obtener una estrella
barrientos logra así el sueño de
replicar el éxito del restaurante con el
mismo nombre que tiene en medellín
bogotá y en miami
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho y sigan viendo france24
[Música]